alerte à la concentration de champion au
mètre carré mercredi soir dernier à
versailles sport scolaire et fédéral les
athlètes du département ont glané 68
titres nationaux cette saison et 11
illinois où participer aux jeux
olympiques
cette soirée des champions c'était aussi
l'occasion de saluer l'investissement du
département qui doit surtout continuer
ou s'améliorer au profit des jeunes
espoirs
je sais que dans les yvelines ya
beaucoup de sportifs et des sportifs qui
aurait qui pourraient de meilleur niveau
si c'était mieux a tenu à accompagner
donc la petit clin d'oeil
les subventions sont toujours les
bienvenus parce que parce qu'il ya
vraiment de quoi faire dans les yvelines
ce sont ces jeunes athlètes qui doivent
prendre la relève à l'horizon des jeux
olympiques à rio en 2016 comme
l'escrimeur trappistes cédric heineken
et champion de france juniors au fleuret
ou léonie perriot championne du monde
juniors de triathlon en attendant avec
cette cérémonie le chapitre jo-2012 est
définitivement clos on commence à
réaliser effectivement qu'on a réalisé
l'un de ses plus gros objectif
un rêve même quasiment on va dire parce
que je pensais vraiment pas aller aux
jeux de 2012 j'avais l'objectif d'aller
un jour en 2016
donc j'ai pris un peu d'avancé sur
l'objectif donc bah on en profite pour
se fixer des objectifs un peu plus haut
et viser 2016 avec
cette fois ci une belle performance
là-bas les joueurs du paris saint
germain christophe jallet et nenê ont
remis les trophées aux athlètes une
soirée qui a dû leur changer les idées
après l'élimination la veille en coupe
de la ligue